mesdames messieurs bonjour je suis mort
le 23 mai 2010 le jour de mon dernier
match de rugby
ce jour là j'ai traversé une ligne
blanche
c'est la ligne blanche qui sépare le
terrain des bons tremplins
remplaçants j'ai traversé la ligne
blanche et je dis au revoir à 25 ans de
rugby une porte s'est refermée derrière
moi à jamais c'est cette porte qui se
referme
quand quitté terrain pour le dernière
fois quand on enlève le maillot pour la
dernière fois et qu'on enlève les
crampons pour la dernière fois
ça s'appelle le petit mort et cette
petite mort nantes et marquer mais elle
a fini par me structurer
mais aujourd'hui je suis pas là pour
temps pour parler de moi je vais vous
parler plus en général de ce sport le
rugby ce sport professionnel qui le
rugby depuis peu d'ailleurs parce que
c'est un sport professionnel jeunes
depuis 95 et je vais vous parler de ces
problématiques particulières qui sait
pas qui se posent possession de rugby
lorsqu'il s'arrête donc je suis là
plutôt pour vous sensibiliser et pour
aussi tiré la sonnette d'alarmé il ya
peu d'années encore le jour de rugby de
haut niveau à lier le pratique de son
sport avec l'exercice de notre métier et
dans cette histoire les clubs joué un
rôle fondamental très important puisque
les clubs étaient là pour élever les
joueurs socialement le club
trouver un travail pour le joueur le
joueur s'intégrer dans la cité et ainsi
on s'occupait de son avenir aujourd'hui
en 2014 je suis pas sûr que les clubs de
top 14
ces deux premières divisions de rugby
français s'occupent de leurs joueurs de
la même façon et après vous pouvez me
dire monsieur fédéral vous êtes gentil
mais ces gens là gagnent très bien leur
vie
ce qui est vrai en partie le salaire
moyen en top 14 et 14000 euros net se
monte on la met même temps pendant peu
de temps et finalement c'est pas tant
que ça et donc la question que je vous
pose que je pourrai aujourd'hui et c'est
de savoir si on paie des joueurs ce
montant là est ce qu'on peut à la fin de
la carrière sont avait les mains donc
pour commencer à répondre à cette
question
j'ai cinq choses à vous dire
cinq choses et les fruits de mon vécu
mais c'est aussi le fruit de mes
échanges ces dernières semaines lorsque
j'ai préparé cette intervention parce
que j'ai beaucoup discuté avec provale
séné cardio de rugby et aussi avec l'
agence quinzaine associations qui
travaillent avec provale qui s'occupe de
la reconversion des joueurs donc
et d'ailleurs je remercie ces personnes
parce que finalement ils ont mis de
l'ordre dans ma tête c'est chose que
j'ai vécue maintenant je peux je vais je
vais vous le livre maintenant à 5.5
chose
première chose c'est le deuil de ma
carrière et dans ma vie de sportif en
général et ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le joueur doit dire au
revoir à certaines choses c'est le fin
des ces moments de bonheur intenses
qu'ils sont vécus
collectivement ces deux fins de ses
joies de la fin de cette déception sur
la fin de cette tristesse parfois c'est
le fin de cette vie privilégiée en
groupe où on est choyé ou
tout est préparé pour nous
minutieusement
c'est la fin de ces moments où le joueur
va chercher quelque chose au fond de
lui-même pour ensuite le livret pour le
donner sur le terrain pour le bien de
l'équipe et ensuite c'est la fin de
cette travail en groupe où on est
solidaire où on est unis où un cherche
des solutions ensemble presque comme un
seul homme c'est les fans de ces moments
là c'est la fin aussi ont dit adieu à
cette reconnaissance sociale ont dit
adieu à la place du sportif dans la
ville et la façon dont téléporté dans le
regard de l'autre
lorsque c'est fini celui pour qui la vie
a été organisée pendant des années
n'essaie plus parce qu'il a plus de
repères c'est lui pour qui on traverse
la rue pour dire bonjour mais c'est plus
que quand ces personnes ne traverse plus
le rue parce que et sait plus qui il est
c'est pas ça le plus difficile le plus
difficile c'est et les plus dans le
groupe i les il a plu ses potes il
ya plus de vie sociale
il ne sait plus ce qui représente pour
moi c'était plus difficile parce que
après en ce sens sa place nulle part on
se sent à sa place nulle part et ça
donne quoi c'est dans cette annonce
anciens sont ses sensations
d'immenses sur l'étude et s'arrange
entre dans la dépression et n'a pas
envie d'en parler parce que ça fait pas
rêver
c'est les aveux de faiblesse et on n'a
pas envie de rester dessus donc ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
un peu plus sur le côté physique
physiologique
pourquoi parce que le jour de rugby en
train de façon intense deux entre deux
entraînements par jour la muscu les
courses des plaquages démêler et c'est
donc il produit beaucoup dans de
morphine
ils ont des films qui circulent dans son
corps on s'arrête c'est très difficile
on peut plus s'entraîner de la même
façon donc on produit plus les zones de
morphine de la même façon
ça fait qu' on n'est plus le même dans
sa tête et dans son corps on se comprend
plus et son entourage non plus troisième
point c'est le côté financier pour les
joueurs de rugby il ya une obligation de
reconversion pourquoi c'est tout simple
c'est parce que le jeu de rugby ne
gagnent pas assez pour assurer leur est
de rester c'est jour le jour le rugby
est encore loin de foot sont loin de
foot donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que de jour de rugby de revoir un métier
passion qu'il a sa place
un métier alimentaire et ça c'est un
gros choc parce qu'on est très très loin
très loin des conditions de travail dans
un grand club de rugby professionnel et
forcément on est très loin de ses
salaires le quatrième point après vous
pouvez penser que ce soit banal mais
c'est sur le côté organisation de vie
parce que quand on est en train de façon
dans un club professionnel semaine on a
des plages de repos on peut se reposer
on fait autre chose on peut aller
récupérer ses enfants à l'école
on peut aller faire les courses on est
disponible et ces deux week-ends où ça
se passe quand s'arrête c'est l'envers
et on comprend pas on voit comme les
gens normaux entre kim et travail
c'est un gros choc et ça donne quoi ça
donne une sens des orientations
importantes aussi le cinquième point
cinquième point ce surplus sur le plan
personnel et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
été soufflée comme ça ce sont plus de
conviction mais parce que par les
statistiques
mais c'est inquiète inquiétant aussi
parce que procédure de rugby il ya un
grand taux de divorce dans les premières
années après la fin de la carrière
donc ça fait 5 points 5 points et c'est
à mon sens c'est déjà pas mal
c'est déjà pas mal donc comme je vous ai
dit c'est le début et pourquoi ce début
parce que le sport professionnel qui le
rugby très jeune depuis 95
on sait plus on ne sait pas comment les
générations qui jouent actuellement vont
vivre l'après rugby
j'avais 18 ans 95 jeudi à cheval entre
le rugby professionnel et le rugby
amateur c'est important pourquoi parce
que j'ai tout je penser à ma
reconversion
je pense que je suis pas spécialement de
mérite
j'ai toujours pensé c'était naturel donc
j'ai continué mes études de droit
pendant toute ma carrière je suis
maintenant avocat c'était mon objectif
j'en suis content voilà encore une fois
si tu es une grande chance parce que
finalement c'était pas dans un centre de
formation à partir de 16 ans 17 ans je
n'étais jamais comment dire couper du
monde du monde réel entre guillemets et
donc avec avec ça en tête avec le
façonne dont je pense avoir prévu de fin
de carrière
quand je pense à cette petite mort je me
dis bon pour moi c'était quand même pas
mal
je me souviens du jour où j'étais dans
nos voitures à toulon quelques mois
après de carrière après la fin de la
carrière je me trouve un feu rouge comme
ça dans une voiture je m'éclate en
larmes tout seul comme ça qu'est ce que
tu fais c'est très étrange mais c'est à
partir de ce moment là j'ai commencé ça
a fait tilt c'est parti à ce moment là
où les anciens autour de moi ont
commencé à se confier et c'est là où
j'ai commencé à comprendre ce que eux
ils avaient vécu
maintenant la sonnette d'alarmé déjà été
tiré à plusieurs reprises il ya un jour
un ancien joueur du stade français pour
le connaissez peut-être raphaël poulain
qui est un peu le ne portera pas le
porte parole de cet exercice entre
guillemets qui a sorti un livre qui
s'appelle quand j'étais superman
il travaille actuellement sur un projet
de film
intitulé les héros meurent jeunes après
avoir vu le teaser de ce film ce film
qui est en train de d'être tournée je
peux vous dire que ça risque d'être
phénoménal j'en ai shared pour le même
montant sans ces témoignages et aussi
comme celui-ci vous ai dit tout à
l'heure il ya provale le syndicat des
joueurs
il ya aussi agence 15 qui travaillent
être étroitement avec des clubs avec les
joueurs surtout sur le présent et sur
l'avenir
il essaie de faire passer des messages
que ce que vous faites maintenant est
très bien mais attendez-vous autre chose
d'ici peu et maintenant la sonnette
d'alarmé peut prendre une forme beaucoup
plus dramatique annoncé une journée
l'ancien capitaine de l'équipe de france
qui finit devant la cour d'assises parce
qu'il a tué sa femme
on constate et puis qu'est ce qu'on fait
on on essaie de responsabiliser et ça
commence ou invention c'est que ça
commence avec des clubs ça commencerait
des clubs et là aussi ses fruits de mes
discussions avec les agences 15
on parle souvent de responsabilité
sociale de l'entreprise
ces notions que j'ai vu dans mes études
c'est une notion que l'on tend à droite
à gauche maintenant dans les clubs de
rugby je suis pas sûr que on est sur une
notion de responsabilité sociale parce
qu'à un moment donné je pense que on y
suit un système on presse les jours les
prestigieux comme des citrons pas
suivant l'expression donc au vu de
sambre à mon sens on est quand même
redevable envers ses joueurs
je pense qu'on peut pas faire
abstraction de son bien-être physique et
mental et surtout de son avenir
et là encore une fois avant les clubs
des clubs élevé les joueurs socialement
maintenant laisser une expression de
lagence 15 on parle d intégration d
intégration sociale
c'est pas mal donc pourquoi pas on
pourrait s'inspirer du modèle néo
zélandais vont embaucher quelqu'un à
plein temps et cette personne s'occupe
justement dans la reconversion des
joueurs sait tous que c'est une
initiative fabuleuse maintenant clavet
aussi chablis aussi responsable et ça
c'est mon avis c'est vraiment personnel
parce que le rugby sport équipe par
excellence prises dans l'affect puisse
dans l'affect ses moteurs et ses langues
fatale d'une équipe parce que le club de
rugby cherche dans l'affect ressources
de la cohésion d'une équipe et la
solidarité d'une équipe donc à la fin
tout a été mis en oeuvre pour qu'on soit
solidaires liés à la fin on quitte ce
groupe on comprend pas on est intéressé
n'a pas fini de formation c'est parce
qu'on fait c'est parce qu'ils où il faut
aller et pour les raisons que je
énumérer plus tôt c'est compliqué pour
les joueurs
donc j'ai fini avec un mot sur la
responsabilité les sociétés société si
je songe aux le formuler comme ça qu'ils
regardent ces joueurs qui les élève au
panthéon est qui qui jouit finalement à
travers à travers eux et comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure on n'a pas trop envie
d'en parler on n'a pas envie de
d'entendre ses aveux de faiblesse parce
que ça fait pas rêver
ce qui fait rêver c'est le rugby club
toulonnais est que ces deux titres sur
le balcon de la mairie de la mairie je
suis d'accord c'est fabuleux
c'est une performance incroyable toulon
rct est devenu la place forte du rugby
européen
maintenant dans cette euphorie il ya
quand même des joueurs qui tirent leur
révérence
j'y pense à eux je pense à eux parce que
deux portes claquent se referment
derrière eux et ont fini dont le noir un
peu tout seul je pense que quelqu'un
comme un joe van niekerk d'être le
connaissez ketty mon capitaine un joueur
exemplaire qui a dynamisé lui tout seul
r c'était avec un coeur énorme
lassé clap de fin l'anonymat et si on
était tous responsables tous
responsables de ce que l'on porte aux
nues ceux qui ont mouillé le maillot qui
ont rempli nos après midis dans les
tribunes dans les canapés ce qu'ils ont
fait
nos conversations et ceux qui ont bercé
nos rêves de jeunesse on consomme en
quelque part nos héros comme sommes un
peu et après on les laisse au bord de la
route
je pense qu'il est l'heure de penser
sérieusement à qui y sont à leur rôle
dans nos vies et à leur place dans la
société qui ne se termine pas le jour où
il traverse la ligne blanche
on en reparlera j'en suis sûr merci